اعربت الصين عن استيائها الشديد من
استخدام الولايات المتحده الامريكيه القوه
في اسقاط المنطاد الذي وصفته واشنطن
بمنطاد التجسس وكان الفانتاغون قد اعلن
اسقادا من المثير للجدل بصاروخ اطلقته
مقاتله امريكيه وسط توتر بين القيادتين
الامريكيه والصينيه زاد شده في ظل تحذيرات
من انزلاقه الى مواجهه مباشره بين البلدين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي حيثيات وظروف
واسقاط المنطاد الصيني فوق الاراضي
الامريكيه وما مغزى استهدافه في هذه
المرحله بالنظر الى وجود حالات سابقه
اخترقت فيها مناطيد صينيه الاجواء
الامريكيه وفي اي سياق دولي
هل يسعى صناع القرار في واشنطن وبجين الى
توظيف هذه الحادثه سياسيا بما يحقق مصالح
ومقارب كل طرف وكيف نقرا ردود الفعل ما
مالات ازمه المنطاد والى اي مدى سيصل
التصعيد بين الجانبين وما هي انعكاساته
الدوليه والاقليميه وكيف ستتاثر به
منطقتنا
[موسيقى]
لم تقتنع واشنطن ولو للحظه بان المنطاد
الصيني الذي اجتاز حدودها كان مجرد منطاد
مدني مخصص للابحاث العلميه ضل طريقه ولم
يهنا بال القياده الامريكيه حتى اسقطته
بعد ان اطلقت عليه صفه من طاد التجسس وزير
الدفاع الامريكي اوستن قال ان عمليه اسقاط
المنطاد الصيني نفذتها مقاتله من طراز اف
المتطوره بعد اعتماد البانتاجون خيارا
امنا بالتنسيق مع الحكومه الكنديه واتهم
اوستن الصين باستخدام المنطاد لمراقبه
مواقع امريكيه استراتيجيه واكد مسؤول في
البنتاجون ان المنطقه جزء من اسطول صيني
يتجسس على القارات الخمس
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اشاد باسقاط
المنطاد الصيني نتابع ما قاله
[موسيقى]
يوم الاربعاء عندما تم اطلاعي على موضوع
المنطاد طلبت من البانتاجون اي يسقطه في
اليوم نفسه باسرع ما يمكن لكنهم قرروا
تفاديا لالحاق الضرر باي شخص انتظار ان
يصبح المنطاد فوق الماء في مجال يبعد 12
ميلا وقد تمكنوا من اسقاطه بنجاح اود ان
اهنئ طيارينا الذين نفذوا عمليه الاسقاط
وستكون لدينا معلومات اكثر نقدمها لاحقا
الخارجيه الصينيه تمسكت بروايتها القائله
ان الامر يتعلق اولا واخيرا بمنطاد مدني
انحرف عن مساره بسبب قوه قاهره المتحدث
باسم الخارجيه الصينيه اعتبر ان اسقاط
المنطاد رد مبالغ فيه وينتهك بشكل خطير
الممارسات الدوليه من وجهه نظره اما وزاره
الدفاع الصينيه فقد قالت ان الصين تحتفظ
بالحق في استخدام الوسائل اللازمه للتعامل
مع المواقف المماثله
[موسيقى]
للنقاش في هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
الكويت الدكتور عبد الله الشيجي استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه الكويت والخبير
في الشؤون الامريكيه ومن بيروت رياض عيد
الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه ابدا معك سيد
رياض ما الذي اغضب الصين الى هذه الدرجه
واستدعى الرد القوي من الخارجيه الصينيه
الم يدخل المنطاد سياده واجواء دوله اخرى
برايي لم يكن امام الصين الا ان تعبر عن
هذا الرفض لاسقاط المنطار الذي ادعت او
التي قالت انه
منطارا مدنيا هو فعلا من طاب مدني
لمراقبه اوضاع الطقس
وكانت هي سابقا قد اعتبرت او صرحت عن
اسفها لان الرياح هي التي حرفت المنطاد
باتجاه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لكن
المنطاد منذ الاربعاء الماضي
يتمخطر في الاجواء الامريكيه وهل هي صدفه
يعني ان يكون
فوق منطقه بنطانه التي فيها
ثالث مركز لاطلاق الصواريخ النوويه باتجاه
العالم من قبل امريكا انا اعتقد ان الصين
كانت تريد ان توجه رساله كبيره الى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وقد نجحت هذه
الرساله الاربعاء الماضي والمنطال يتمخطر
في الاجواء الامريكيه كل التقارير تشير
نعم
الرساله بالتحديد
وما هو المعيار الذي نقيس على اساسه نجاح
الرساله من عدمه في هذه الحاله
اولا هناك تحركات امريكيه كبيره في بحر
الصين هناك اشكاليات كبيره تقيمها امريكا
واحلاف كبيره تقيمها ضد الصين من حلف
الكواس الى
الكواد الى القواعد التي تنشرها في
المنطقه
لتضييق على الصين ومنذ يومين كان
الوزير الدفاع في الفلبين واستاجر ارض
لنصف صواريخ يعني هناك محاوله احتواء
التقدم الصيني والتطور الصيني من قبل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذا بالاضافه
الى الصراع الاقتصادي القائم بين الصين
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه على زعامه
الكون اقتصاديا في ظل هذه المناخات
والتحشيد الامريكي باتجاه الصين وتحديدا
التوتر الذي قام بمنطقه تايوان بعد زياره
نانسيبيروتسي والتنكر امريكا وان لم اقل
انها امريكا قد تنكرت لكن عدم يعني العدم
البقاء امريكا على اعتبار ان تايوان هي
جزء من الصين الواحده كل هذه المناخات انا
اعتقد انه بالنسبه الى الصين اعتبرت ان
الامور فقط قدرتها على التحمل لذلك اتى
هذا المنطاد كرساله الى الامريكيين باننا
نستطيع ان نحن ايضا نتجسس على الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ونوجه رسائل علها
تستطيع ان ترجع الولايات البحر الامريكيه
عن هذه الحركات والتكتلات العسكريه في بحر
الصين نعم هي رساله
من بحر السيد نعم رساله من الصين الى
امريكا لو سمحت لسيد عبد الله هل طريقه
اسقاط الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لهذا
المنطاد هي رساله مقابله من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الى الصين ما الذي دفع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الى اعتماد
هذا المطلوب في اسقاط المنطاد
يعني المنطاد هو جزء من المشكله وهو ما
نسميه يعني قمه جبل الجليد هناك
صراع على تشكيل نظام عالمي جديد الصين
وروسيا تريان بانهما لديهم الحق بان تكون
لهم دور وبصمه في هذا النظام العالمي
الجديد الذي يقارع ويرفض الهيمنه
الامريكيه ونحن نتحول الى نظام عالمي جديد
يعني حتى الامريكان منذ 15 سنه الذي يقرا
للاسف كثير من المحللين
والباحثين لا يقراون ما تصدره امريكا
بالعلن من
ما تسمى
ومجلس خاصه
الاستخبارات الامريكيه يتكلمون وانا اقرر
على طلبتي في الجامعه يتكلمون عن اننا
نتحول الى نظام عالمي متعدد الاقطاب
بالصين وروسيا تريدان ان تفرضان نوعا ما
من رايهما في هذه في هذا النظام القادم
المنطاد هذا مره نسمع انه حتى وظيف يعني
ناقض نفسها مره يقول مدني لاغراض كما تقول
الصين الطقس والاجواء ومره يقول لا ارسل
للتجسس يعني فهو واضح انه الصين تريد ان
ترسل عده رساله الاولى تعلم الصين ان
امريكا ستسقطه لانه لاول مره مساره بدا من
المحيط الهادي ثم دخل الى الاسكا ثم الى
كندا وامريكا تتبعه منذ يوم الاربعاء
الماضي البانتاجون ابلغ الرئيس بان هناك
خيارات ولكن نفضل ان لا نسقطه فوق الاراضي
الامريكيه حتى يصل الى محيط الاطلسي
وبالفعل الصين تعلم انه سيسقط الصين كانت
تحاول الحصول على صور
ترسل مباشره من المنطاد الى الصين ولكن
الامريكان نجحوا بالتشويش على ذلك هذه
ثلاث مرات في عهد الرئيس كما يقول
البانتاجون في عهد الرئيس ترامب
اخترقت الصين المجال الامريكي بثلاث
مناطيد ولم يتم اسقاطها ولكن ليس بهذا
الحجم وبهذه المساحه الهائله التي عبرت من
اقصى شمال الغربي الامريكي الى الوسط
الجنوب ورحل الى المحيط الاطلسي حتى عشبه
ومره في عهد بايدن اذا كان هذا التصعيد هو
جزء من الزعامه الصراع على الزعامه وهذا
متوقع
يعني حتى الطريقه التي تم اسقاط المنطاد
بها هل هي ايضا تقع او تاتي في سياق ما
ذكرت يعني ايضا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تارود على انتهاك السياده بهذا
بهذا بهذه الطريقه القويه بانزاله عبر
مقاتله وليس محاصرته وانزاله هل يمكن فهم
الطريقه بمعزل عن السياق الذي وضعت فيه
التوتر الصيني الامريكي
هذا سؤال مهم طبعا
استخدمت بعد اعطى الرئيس بايدن الاوامر
باسقاطها بعد ان اصبح فوق المياه الاطلسي
اقلع الطائرتين اف 22 رابتر اللي هي احدث
طائرات في العالم
ثمن الطائره الواحده 200 مليون دولار
اطلقوا صاروخ واحد فقط كل فتره 400 مليار
400 الف دولار وتم اسقاطها بضربه واحده
وهذه رساله للصين ورساله لخصوم امريكا
ولحلفاء الصين باننا نستطيع ان نمنع اي
اختراقات اذا اردنا وبهذه الطريقه
المسرحيه الهولوهيوديه كانت ايضا وطبعا
هذا تحول في الداخل الامريكي الى صراع
الجمهوريه ينتقدون ضعف بايدن ويقولون بان
بايدن كان يجب ان يسقطه من اول ما دخل
الاراضي الامريكيه في الاسكا بينما
الديمقراطي يثنون على رباطه جيش بايدن
ولكن في نهايه الامر رسائل متبادله وصلت
من الصين عندنا قدره عندنا تكنولوجيا
نستطيع ان نخترق سيادتكم ونستطيع ايضا ان
نعبث كما انتم تعبثون في منطقتنا وفي
جوارنا ولا الصين الحق بذلك ولكن في نفس
الوقت نرى بان هناك في تصعيد وهذا يضرب
يعني كان في تقارب جيد في قمه العشرين
مجموعه العشرين في اندونيسيا في نوفمبر
الماضي وكان على وشك ان يغادر وزير
الخارجيه بلنكن يوم الجمعه الى بكين
ويجتمع لاول مره مع الرئيس الصيني ومع
نظيره ولكن الان الامور تعقدت وتصير كمن
يطلق رصاصه على قدمي طبعا الصين تستغل هذا
الصينيه يعني المشاهير والانفلونسر في
الصينغ يسخرون من امريكا ويستهزئون بها
مثل ما ضايفكم تكلموا يتمخطر
المنطاد
الصيني فوق الاراضي الامريكيه امريكا كانت
تستطيع ان تسقطه من اول لحظه ولكن كانت
تخشى من اضراره وسقوط على مناطق سكنيه عبد
الله
ولكن دعني اسمع من السيد رياض سيد رياض
يعني حضرتك والسيد عبد الله اجمعتم على
انه لا يمكن فهم قضيه المنطاد وكيفيه
اسقاطه الا عبر السياق التي ياتي فيها
الذي ياتي فيه بالتالي كيف يمكن ان ترد
الصين في ظل التوتر التي شرحته حضرتك
وايضا الدكتور عبد الله
ويعني التزاحم والتنافس بين الجانبين على
الزعامه
اولا الصين حتى الان الصراع بين الصين
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه ياخذ بعدا
اقتصاديا تكنولوجيا
والصراع على الرقائق الالكترونيه وعلى
الذكاء الصناعي على يعني بترول بترول
القرن القادم التي هو الذي هو الرقائق
الالكترونيه هذا الصراع الاقتصادي هو صراع
محتدم وعلى اواجه بين الولايات التحرير
الامريكيه والصين ايضا بالاضافه الى هذا
الصراع كما قلت نعم ولكن يتحدث عن مواجهه
عسكريه في عام 2025
الاتفاقات التي تعقدها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه مع الدول المجاوره للصين هي
اتفاقيات عسكريه
نعم نعم انا ساصل الى هذا الامر رغم رغم
ان كل التحشيد الامريكي في بحر الصين وفي
جوار الصين هو تحشيد لتهديد الصين ومنعه
من ان يعني تستطيع ان تنفذ اهدافها
وتحديدا برامجها العسكريه لان الصين بعد
المؤتمر الاخير للحزب الشيوعي الصيني حدثت
استراتيجياتها بشكل ان تحمي قواتها طرق
التجاره وحضورها العالم في البحار الكونيه
في البحار العالميه وبالتالي يعني الاسطول
الصيني
والغواصات الصينيه النوويه
تطورت بشكل غير عادي بالاضافه الى السلاح
الفرد صوتي بالتنسيق مع روسيا الذي طورته
الصين لكني اقول ان هذا الصراع المحتدم
بين الصين وامريكا اعتقد انا لبى الاجزم
انه سيبقى في
الصراع الاقتصادي لان الدولتين دولتين
نوويتين وهناك تقارير منذ ايام عهد ترامب
اجمع ترامب مجموعه من مجموعه الازمه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كي
تقيم محاكاه ان وقع الصدام بين الولايات
تحت الامريكيه والصين لمن ستكون الغلبه
كانت النتيجه ان الجرارات الامريكيين
نصحوا الرئيس
بعدم الدخول في المواجهه لان قدرات الصين
تستطيع ان يعني تضرب كل القواعد الامريكيه
في المنطقه بما فيها قاعده جوان وبعد
المسافه بين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبحر الصين
والقرب الصين من هذه المسافه تستطيع الصين
ان يعني تحسم هذه المعركه لذلك انا اعتقد
بين
نوويتين الصدام هو مكلف جدا ولا اعتقد ان
امريكا قد تذهب في هذا الاطار رغم ان هناك
كما ذكرتي تقارير من جرارات امريكيين
حددوا عام 2025 هو يوم عام استدام العسكري
بين امريكا والصين انا اعتقد ان المصالح
الامريكيه الصينيه كبيره جدا
الاقتصاديه عيت بها رغم كل هذا الصراع
الظاهر
للعيان يعني حتى في ظل هذه الخلافات
الكبيره والعقوبات الكبيره العام الماضي
كانت تبادل التجاري بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والصين رغم العقوبات
649 مليار دولار
والفارق بالميزان التجاري لمصلحه الصين
بحدود 385 مليار دولار يعني رغم كل هذه
الخلافات لا يزال التبادل التجاري قائم
لذلك انا اعتقد ان الصراع هو على الموضوع
الاقتصادي وهناك تضييق عسكري لمحاوله سني
الصين عن اكمال مشروعه بان تتزعم الكون
اقتصاديه فعلا كما ذكر نعم كما ذكر ضيفي
ايضا على زعامه القرن الجديد دكتور عبد
الله هل
سيقف التوتر والصراع بين الجانبين عند
حدوده الاقتصاديه الى اين يذهب هذا التوتر
انا اتفق مع الضيف من بيروت بان بالفعل
يعني هناك يعني ما يجري هو صراع واضح ان
الصين الان كشرت عن انيابها الصين عملاق
كبير تملك موارد تملك طاقه ولك عندها
مشكله الاقتصاد هو اقتصاد تصديري وليس
انوفيشن وليس ابتكاري ولكن الصين قاعده
تشتغل على هذه النقطه وحسب الدراسات
الامنيه والاستخباراتيه الامريكيه واخرها
دراسه
الاستراتيجيه الامن الوطني واستراتيجيه
الدفاع الوطني الامريكيه التي صدرتها بشهر
اكتوبر الماضي تؤكد مره اخرى ان الصين هي
الدوله الوحيده التي تملك القدره ولديها
كجميع الامكانيات لتكون المنافسه الاول
للزعامه الامريكيه في المنطقه واذا تحالفت
مع روسيا سيكون الوضع اصعب للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والصين تقارع امريكا في
كثير من المجالات منها التكنولوجيا ومنها
احد الرسائل التي ارسلت بالبنط الصيني ان
عندنا ايضا القدره الفضائيه المنافس
امريكا ونطلق ايضا اقمار صناعيه ونصل الى
القمر حتى والصين هي دوله رئيسيه الان من
الدول التي بالتكنولوجيا بالفايف جي
بالسكتجي بهواوي وحتى يعني ما تملكه الصين
من تيك توك يمثل تهديد كما تقول امريكا
لامنها الوطني يعني وصل الى هذا المستوى
فالصراع سيستمر ولكن سيبقى محدودا الردع
النووي هو الذي منع حرب عالميه ثالثه لهذا
السبب مهما مهما هدد وتوعد بوتين كما ذكرت
انا على الجزيره منذ سبعه اشهر عندما كان
يعني في الافق يوجد تلميحات لاستخدام
النووي قد لن يستخدم النوع لان النووي ليس
مزحه وليس لعبه لانه يستخدم للنصل الى
النووي ما تصدره الدراسات الامريكيه هو
تهويل لفقط ردع الصين انه في مواجهه قادمه
بالفين وخمسه وعشرين او غير هذا هذا لا
يركن اليه لان الدول الن لا تتقاتل مع
بعضها البعض تتقاتل حول نفوذ في مناطق
مهمه لا يعني ما يزعج الصين واتفق انا مع
الصين ان امريكا تعربد في منطقه نفوذها ما
نسميه سفير اوف انفلونس مناطق النفوذ يعني
الصين ترى بان بحر الصين الجنوبي والبحر
الاصفر هو منطقه نفوذ خالصه للصين وليس
لامريكا التي تدعم حلفائها الذين خاصه
كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان والفلبين الان
اصبح عندهم 6 قواعد امريكيه فامريكا تحاصر
الصين بتحالفات ايضا مع استراليا بالاوكس
ومع الاكواد مع الهند وهذا كله تفسره
الصين ان موجها ضدها ولهذا تريد ان ترسل
رساله لامريكا نحن نستطيع ايضا ان نلعب
معكم كما تلعبون معنا ولهذا السبب اللعبه
ستطول وتتعقد وستتكرر يتكرر عبد الله هل
ستبقى القنوات الدبلوماسيه مفتوحه بعد
الغاء زياره بلينكن يعني هل استخدمت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه قضيه المنطاد
كذريعه لالغاء هذه الزياره وبالتالي ماذا
عن الافق الدبلوماسي بين الجانبين
لا لا ستبقى يعني يعني حتى وقت المنطاد في
اشد الازمات كان في تواصل بين امريكا وبين
القياده في الصين الصين لم تخبر
الامريكاندا بالفعل كان عندها نيه صادقه
وان يعني كلام فاضي كلام الخارجيه الصينيه
ان
البالون او المنطاد ضل طريقه بسبب الهواء
شو الكلام الفاضي اذا ضل الطريق بسبب
الفضاء تتصل بالقياده الامريكيه وتخبرها
بذلك يعني واضح انه منطاد تجسس مهما بلغت
الحده والتصعيد تبقى الباك تشانلز
والمفاوضات السريه وتحت الطاوله مستمره
امريكا الصين لديها اكبر استثمار في
صناديق صناديق سيادتها في امريكا في
30 سنه الامريكيه او اكبر
زبون تجاري مع امريكا نعم في 30 ثانيه
وهنا اتحول للسيد رياض سيد رياض باسقاط
هذا المنطاد هل وفي ظل هذا التوتر هل
ستنتهي حرب المناطيد يعني نشاهد هنا جسم
اخر في كولومبيا
لا اعتقد انها ستنتهي انا اعتقد ان حرب
التجسس والمعلومات هي قائمه بشكل كبير بين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والصين
والولايات تحت الامريكيه واوروبا وروسيا
لذلك انا لا اعتقد ان الامور ستنتهي عند
هذا الحد هناك حساب مفتوح امني بين
العمالقه خاصه العمالقه النوويين لان
الخطوره في التعاطي هي في هذا السباق من
التسلح والتعبئه النوويه بهذا الاتجاه
رياضه عيد البحث في العلاقات الدوليه كنت
معنا من بيروت نشكرك ونشكر ايضا الدكتور
عبد الله الشايجي استاذ العلوم السياسيه
في جامعه الكويت والخبير في الشؤون
الامريكيه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]